when you know it is Facebook Instagram
everybody kind of giving uh Trump uh uh
uh reinstating them on the accounts I
think a lot of these guys and including
YouTube maybe firing Susan the CEO of
YouTube maybe a lot of these guys are
sitting there saying dude let's just
make sure they don't Target and find
that our freaking YouTube files what if
they find out Facebook files and
Instagram files holy if they figure
this part out so listen let's kind of
accommodate let's kind of slow our role
on the strikes and the Banning and this
and that and let's kind of let people
lose a little bit more let's kind of
know that this is going to be the year
of Investigations fauci and Twitter
files and you know uh Biden and Hunter
Biden and all they're going to be
investigating everybody let's just pump
the brakes
[Music]
[Applause]